once you have the referrals and the
testimonials you post the testimonials
which is this is the method we did
here's the result afterwards this is the
benefit they experienced let me know if
you're interested anybody who engages
you can DM them with a better offer of
like hey this is my that was my first
10. my next 10 I'm doing for half off
give them some sort of incentive to do
it so that's a benefit for prepaying the
whole package those are not super hard
right hooks because they're inspiring
for a lot of people people think it's
cool and then you have call to action
switch drive into your DMs and then you
can upsell them from there right if you
do a good job the word of mouth